this is extreme gardening
these thai divers are planting baby
coral
in the murky water they swim against the
current painstakingly sticking them to
an artificial reef
and these corals have a secret weapon
they can survive higher sea temperatures
which have decimated reefs worldwide
right now climate change are killing a
corals in these regions particularly in
the upper gulf of thailand so what we
try to do
is to restore the coral by collecting
coral egg and sperm and then fertilize
it and then we raise them until two
years old and during the two years we
try to make them adapt to the rising
temperatures
this is what happens to coral when the
water gets too hot
rising sea temperatures pollution and
too much sun can all cause bleaching
algae needed to stay healthy as expelled
leaving them white and vulnerable it's a
killer issue between 2009 and 2018
14 of coral worldwide died
coral is being killed by human activity
and climate change and that isn't just a
big problem for marine life but also for
the 500 million humans who rely on it
for jobs food and protection from the
sea
growing a more heat resistant species
involves a kind of coral ivf
sperm and eggs are released in these
little pink sacks
so every night for three months the team
collects and separates them
this is about 8 years old
the coral is then grown in a nursery
it can survive 34 degrees celsius
whereas water over 32 degrees can kill
wild coral
scientists have predicted in the next 30
years
if we not do anything
more than 95 percent of the coral reef
around the world will be disappeared so
it's quite scary so i think it's time
for us to do something seriously about
the climate change
with the help of the thai navy the
scientists are also creating more
artificial reefs
submerging concrete cubes to attach
their coral to
so far they've grown more than 10 000
but if emissions keep rising reefs don't
stand a chance
if
coral reefs die out can the world
survive
very good question i don't think so
scientists around the world are now
fighting to save our reefs but a global
commitment is needed to prevent a
universal tragedy siobhan robbins sky
news in thailand